Okay.
It's been a few weeks and as promised, I am
going to recommend some books to you.
Read a book this week.
Last week I actually got a ton of reading
done and I've got some stuff to recommend
to you as always, David pakman.com/recommendations
okay.
All of my recommendations from this week and
prior weeks and months and years are listed
there.
If you use the links there to buy these books,
we get a little bit of a cut.
We get, as Andrew Yang likes to say, a slice
of an Amazon transaction.
You will be slicing off a piece of your transaction
if you buy these books or any others that
I recommend by going through the links at
David pakman.com/recommendations okay.
First, a nonfiction recommendation.
I have owned this book for a long time and
finally got around to reading it in cold blood
by the great Truman Capote thing.
This is a nonfiction, uh, but it's really
the, it's literary prose of the highest level,
but it is really a sort of police following
a police investigation of a, a series of horrible
murders that happened in Holcomb, Kansas.
It is Kansas, right?
I hope I'm saying that correctly.
It is a top notch.
Truman Capote [inaudible].
It is an extraordinary story that is all the
more horrible because it is real and it simultaneously
follows and then weaves together the story
of those who were murdered.
The story of the murderers and the story of
the multi-agency investigation that took place
in the late fifties and it is also interesting,
just know the, it's the background of this
is Kansas society in the middle of the 20th
century and that is also really, really interesting
to look at a culturally, so I highly recommend
this book in cold blood by Truman Capote.
I have two fiction recommendations for you
today.
Now the first one, this may come as a shock
to some people because I don't typically recommend
this type of thing.
I had never read anything by Stephen King
in my life until a few months ago, and I posted
on Twitter, I want to read something by Stephen
King.
A lot of the recommendations were his older
stuff, but a lot of people said, read his
new book, newish book, the outsider.
And I got it and I read it and it is a really
enjoyable read and now I don't think I'm spoiling
anything.
When I say I liked the book more until a supernatural
element entered the story, I'll just say that
to avoid ruining it for everybody, uh, because
I'm just not really in I, I like PSI Phi,
but I'm not into sort of like fantasy elements,
although magical realism I do like.
Um, but in any case, it's a quick read despite
being nearly 600 pages or something like that,
500 pages.
It is a relatively quick read.
It was enjoyable and it would probably get
me to read another Stephen King book, um,
in a year or something like that.
That is one recommendation.
Here is another fiction recommendation and
this is one of my, I would say one of my favorite
new fiction books.
What year is this from?
From the last couple of years.
This is from, it's from 2018 okay.
In any case, this book is the Knicks by Nathan
Hill.
Okay.
This is a book, I don't even know how to describe
this book, but it weaves together like a present
day ish story with a path story earlier in
the 20th century in the United States.
It combines elements of a suspenseful, a suspenseful
thriller with literary fiction.
And I don't really want to tell you much more
about the story other than to say it crosses
genres and I think that almost any reader
of good fiction would enjoy this book.
The Nicks by Nathan Hill.
Do I want to say anything else about it?
Um, I guess not.
I mean it's just, it's really one of my favorite
new fiction books, non Saifai new fiction
of the last couple of years.
Three recommendations for you.
Read one of them, read all of them, read something
else from my list of recommendations@davidpakmandotcomslashrecommendationsandrememberthatanythingyoubuythatistoatdavidpakman.com
slash
recommendations we get a slice of it and uh,
you're supporting the work that we do, so
make sure to check that out.